the Disney Plus show Ahsoka is the
culmination of Decades of Star Wars
storytelling here's how the series
brings together the animated Rebel Saga
and the ongoing tale of the Mandalorian
before Ahsoka premieres it might be a
good idea to do a little research on the
force user who lends the show its name
Star Wars fans who have only watched the
franchise's live-action movies and TV
shows might not have been too familiar
with thehsoka Tano prior to her
appearances in the Mandalorian and the
Book of Boba Fett but the character has
actually been around for quite a while
she first appeared as Anakin Skywalker's
Padawan in the Clone Wars movie and then
was a regular on the Animated Series
Star Wars the Clone Wars and Star Wars
Rebels Anakin is initially hesitant to
train her but he agrees after she
impresses him by Saving his life during
a fight all is well in ahsoka's Jedi
training until she is framed for the
bombing of the Jedi Temple after which
she has stripped of her Padawan status
and thrown out of the Jedi Order Anakin
Works to prove her innocence which he
does Ahsoka is then invited to rejoin
the order but she declines Ahsoka then
fought for the Rebellion under the Alias
fulcrum during her time fighting for the
Rebellion Ahsoka faces Vader and
confirms that he is her former Master
before narrowly escaping with her life
Ahsoka also also comes across Grand
Admiral thrawn who disappeared with her
friend the Jedi Ezra Bridger the
character first appeared in live action
in season 2 episode 5 of the Mandalorian
where she revealed baby Yoda's real name
Ahsoka then pops up again in season 1
episode 6 of The Book of Boba Fett to
meet with Luke Skywalker before once
again stepping away from the Jedi Order
to go on her own Journey
2023 has been an exciting year for Star
Wars fans din jar in returned and all
his best car plated glory in the
Mandalorian season 3. then in April at
Star Wars celebration in London
producers announced we'd be getting
three brand new movies in the franchise
including one that will feature the
return of Daisy Ridley and one that will
focus on the birth of the force that's
all on top of the debut of Ahsoka the
first episode of which hits Disney Plus
on August 23rd the show will consist of
Eight Episodes which will most likely
air weekly so viewers can expect to be
watching the series finale in late
September or early October while there
is no guarantee it is possible that the
first two episodes of the series may
drop at the same time as they did for
the Obi-Wan Kenobi Series in 2022
however the Mandalorian and the Book of
Boba Fett which are more closely linked
with Ahsoka only premiered with one
episode per season so that's probably
more likely Ahsoka is a very layered
series with villains coming out the
titular character on multiple fronts she
will simultaneously face balance skull
and shinhati whose motives are unknown
and then there's Grand Admiral thrawn
whom she is seeking out of course many
plot details for Ahsoka are being kept
Under Wraps but we do know quite a bit
about ahsoka's mission to find thrawn
back in the second season of The
Mandalorian Ahsoka confronted the
villainous magistrate Morgan ellsbeth
and asked where she could find thrawn
where is Grand Admiral thrawn in the
first trailer for Ahsoka there's a very
quick glimpse of that blue-skinned
Baddie who resembles thrawn quite a bit
for those not in the know thrawn hails
from a series of novels written by
Timothy Zahn where he's a brilliant
leader who commands what's left of the
Empire and fights back against the New
Republic the character made his TV debut
in the Animated Series Star Wars Rebels
in which he disappeared alongside Ezra
Bridger not everyone seems to be as wary
of thrawn as Ahsoka teasing what viewers
can expect from ahsoka's Mission Rosario
Dawson who plays Ahsoka told IGN she
sees a threat other people people aren't
safe he's formidable not somebody to
take lightly she has a sense that
there's something she knows that these
foes are not easily dismissed with the
help of Mandalorian Sabine Wren Ahsoka
plans to hunt thrawn down while also
searching for Ezra
Rosario Dawson appeared as Ahsoka Tano
in both the Mandalorian and the Book of
Boba Fett replacing voice actress Ashley
Eckstein who voiced the character on
clone wars and Rebels Dawson was a big
deal long before entering the Star Wars
Universe making a name for herself in
projects including kids Clerks 2 Death
Proof and Daredevil playing Ahsoka is
clearly the role of a lifetime for
Dawsonville the actor told Vanity Fair
that it's a part she hopes to hold on to
for a long time to come saying as long
as they want me and as long as it's
possible I'm in it Dawson's desire to
play the former Jedi does not seem to be
just because of the fame she'll get from
the Star Wars universe but because she
genuinely cares about and relates to her
character in an interview with IGN
Dawson discussed what drives Ahsoka she
noted that even though Ahsoka isn't a
Jedi anymore that desire to do good and
be of service Still Remains a part of
her we begin to see this in the
Mandalorian when she frees the people of
corvus from the control of magistrate
Morgan elsbath Ray Stevenson plays a
major villain in Ahsoka a force-wielding
dark Jedi by the name of Valen's skull
the trailer makes clear that balen is
going to face off against Ahsoka at
least once and Ivana stock knows
shinhati is going to be working closely
by his side although this part would
appear to be just another in a long long
list of fantasy action and adventure
roll Stevenson has played including
Titus Polo in Rome Blackbeard and Black
Sails oh there and Vikings and volstag
and Thor to name just a few it's a role
he was very excited about Stevenson
gushed to Entertainment Weekly about
every aspect of the show's production
from the writing to the set design to
the stunt team he said you can't wait to
get back to set and see what's going to
be revealed that day what excited him
the most was the twists and turns of his
and shin storyline he teased that it
will constantly keep viewers guessing
unfortunately Stevenson died before he
could see everyone's hard work come
together the guardian reported that he
was taken to the hospital and treated
for an undisclosed illness while filming
a project called casino and iskia on the
Italian island the northern Irish actor
died shortly after on May 21st 2023
Ahsoka isn't the only character from
Star Wars Rebels who will appear in live
action in the new series Natasha Lou
bordizo Who you might recognize from
projects including day shift and the
greatest showman will star as the
Mandalorian warrior Sabine Wren Mary
Elizabeth Winstead who you've no doubt
seen in things like Scott Pilgrim Vs the
World 10 Cloverfield Lane and season 3
of Fargo will play twilik pilot Hera
sindula Iman espandi of the inspection
and King Richard will be portraying Ezra
Bridger a Jedi who's been missing ever
since Star Wars Rebels the robotic huye
whose Long trained Jedi on how to build
lightsabers will be voiced by the one
and only David Tennant who actually won
an Emmy for portraying the character in
The Clone Wars and or Alum Genevieve
O'Reilly will yet again play mon mothma
the leader of the Rebel Alliance On the
Dark Side Ivana sakno the Pacific Rim
Uprising will play The Deadly shin-hati
who takes down anyone in her way Lars
Mickelson will also reprise the role of
grand Admiral thrawn the Danish actor
and brother of mass Mickelson voiced
thrawn in Rebels and you may have also
seen him in projects such as Sherlock
and House of Cards he'll be joined here
by Wes Chatham of the expanse playing
his number one Lackey we also know that
Diana Lee in Asante will reprise her
role as Morgan elsbeth after losing her
duel with Ahsoka in the Mandalorian
George Lucas was the driving creative
force behind the Star Wars franchise for
decades but ever since he sold the
franchise to Disney in 2012 others have
taken the helm including John Favreau
J.J Abrams Kathleen Kennedy and a man
who's had a huge impact on how fans view
the franchise Dave filoni he directed
The Animated Clone Wars movie oversaw
the Clone Wars series created Star Wars
Rebels and has been one of the executive
producers of the Mandalorian felony will
also be a major figure when it comes to
Ahsoka serving as showrunner he's
executive producing writing all the
episodes and even directing a few
himself Ahsoka Tano is a character dear
to felony's heart after all he
co-created the taguru to force user with
George Lucas many fans would argue he's
the only person to bring her story to
the screen and do it justice so we can't
wait to see what filoni has in store for
this next chapter in the Star Wars saga
this is a Monumental moment not just for
ahsoka's character in the franchise but
for filoni on a personal level he spent
years of his life creating developing
and sculpting the character of Ahsoka
Tano and helming this TV show is a dream
moment in his career he told The
Hollywood Reporter writing and directing
and collaborating on this type of thing
with so many people is just the top of
the mountain for me at this point
One Man created all of the early Star
Wars music composer John Williams but
many others have followed in his
footsteps in recent years including
Kevin kiner who will compose the score
for Ahsoka this is not kiner's first
foray into the music of the Star Wars
Universe by any means kainer says he was
inspired by William's work early on in
his career and he went on to compose the
music for the animated series The Clone
Wars Rebels the bad batch and tales of
the Jedi over the years he's put his own
spin on the Star Wars Sound by
introducing a lot of percussion
initially under George Lucas's
instructions and focusing on electronic
sound working on Ahsoka is a full circle
moment for kainer the theme song for
ahsoka's character was the first project
he worked on for Dave filoni and George
Lucas he explained to cine concerts I
remember writing for that theme and I
used a Japanese flute called a
shakuhachi just trying to feel her
femininity but her strength there's this
light and there's a Darkness to her and
there's both of that in her theme you
know there were so many elements I was
trying to put in ahsoka's theme and I'm
really proud of ahsoka's theme
as mentioned Dave filoni is directing
three of the show's Eight Episodes for
the other five Steph Green Peter Ramsey
Jennifer getzinger Gita Patel and Rick
famuyiwa will take turns sitting in the
director's chair and they each bring
with them a wealth of experience in the
action and sci-fi genres
Steph green is Fresh Off directing the
second episode of The Book of Boba Fett
so she'll be ready to hit the ground
running with Ahsoka her other
directorial credits include episodes of
shows including Watchmen deremy and Luke
Cage similarly Spider-Man into the
spider-verse co-director Peter Ramsey's
latest gig was directing an episode of
the Mandalorian the fifth episode of the
third season which saw multiple separate
storylines playing out at once he could
be set to tackle a similar setup Midway
through Ahsoka frequent Marvel TV
director Jennifer getzinger brings vast
experience working on female-led TV
shows like Agent Carter good girls
Revolt Jessica Jones and dead to me
she's helped to shape Fierce characters
including Peggy Carter Jessica Jones and
Jen Harding so getzinger's episode will
no doubt showcase ahsoka's Inner
Strength Gita Patel has similar
experience having also directed episodes
of dead to me as well as episodes of
sci-fi dramas like Marvel's runaways and
HBO's hit Game of Thrones prequel House
of the Dragon rounding out the
directorial list is the Mandalorian
executive producer and director Rick
familywa who will no doubt have a handle
on how Ahsoka fits into the bigger
picture of the mandoverse it's official
Hayden Christensen is returning for
another fight he was last seen in
Obi-Wan Kenobi but it makes sense that
he's returning again since he and Ahsoka
have a history many years have passed
since Obi-Wan's adventure to save
Princess Leia and now ahsokan knows
Darth Vader's identity having phased him
previously in Star Wars Rebels although
Christensen hasn't let on much about his
upcoming appearance he previously teased
how excited he was about his expanding
role so viewers should expect a lot more
than a one-off appearance along with
Christensen there are a few other
characters from the mandovers who might
also appear since they have a connection
to and share the same timeline as Ahsoka
these include Katie sackhoff's Boca tan
crease and Pedro Pascal's din Jaren to
Moira Morrison is ahsoka's Clone Trooper
buddy Captain Rex could also make an
appearance with the actor having
previously starred in The Book of Boba
Fett Ahsoka showrunner Dave filoni
admitted that for many years creating
the Star Wars series seemed like a dream
that would never happen but eventually
he started working on it for real and
he's been planning writing and rewriting
Ahsoka Tano story ever since
unsurprisingly her story has changed
over time and this is partly because of
all the new entries into the Star Wars
universe that have helped bring Ahsoka
to life he told Empire I never would
have imagined that it was sprung from a
branch of a tree that had anything to do
with a guy like din Jaron or a child
that looks like Yoda but it's a great
lesson for me on how when you have other
creatives like John Favreau that can
help lend such Dimension and depth to
what you're doing baloney credits favro
lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy and
director Ryan Johnson for helping guide
him through this process which has
ultimately shaped ahsoka's Journey
Ahsoka Tano's appearance in the
Mandalorian is set up in a way that
leads viewers to believe she will be the
one who will train grogu however after
spending a few days with him and seeing
how he interacts with his surrogate
father she says she cannot be the one to
train the child Ahsoka instead offers a
vague promise that another Jedi will
reach out and offer to take grogu as a
Padawan although that ends up being Luke
Skywalker Ahsoka was originally the one
the Mandalorian Creator John Bavaro
wanted as grogu's mentor
Dave filoni had to put his foot down on
this plan though there's a very specific
reason that Ahsoka turned grogu away he
revealed to Empire magazine I was
telling John that as much as I wanted to
have Ahsoka in the show she can't take
this kid on that's just not what I have
planned
Ahsoka picks up after the finale of Star
Wars Rebels with the last scenes of the
Animated Series being recreated in live
action given that it was impossible for
Ahsoka to take on grogu's training and
continue her own personal mission she's
still dealing with the aftermath of
facing Vader Grand Admiral thrawn's
looming Ascent to power and Ezra's
disappearance storylines that will
continue in the upcoming series
Dave vellone and John Favreau have made
it clear that they want anyone to be
able to jump in and watch their Star
Wars shows without having seen other
shows or movies before however they also
revealed that Ahsoka is going to be a
reward for longtime Star Wars fans who
are invested in the franchise although
the exact time period of Ahsoka hasn't
been confirmed it makes sense that the
series would follow ahsoka's appearances
in the Mandalorian and its sister Boba
Fett series
that places the show in the new Republic
era but as the Mandalorian has proven
that doesn't mean it's a time of peace
and in the trailer the titular character
teases that she has heard rumors of
grand Admiral thrawn becoming the heir
to the Empire the Imperial Remnant is
strengthening and it looks like Ahsoka
is going to be thrown right into the
middle of it John Favreau told IGN these
are characters with a lot of political
implications to what's happening in the
meta-narrative in Star Wars and those
characters and these storylines start to
demand that you deal with larger forces
and bigger Trends within that time
period so viewers can expect the series
to have bigger ramifications for the
Star Wars Universe rather than be a
completely self-contained story all eyes
are on Dave filoni as Disney plus gears
up to release Ahsoka in the summer of
2023. according to the showrunner
viewers should get ready to have their
minds blown according to Star Rosario
Dawson in an interview with the Laughing
Place felony has equated watching the
series with a religious experience after
seeing one of the episodes edited
together bologna told Empire that what
makes Ahsoka so special is her ability
to bridge that gap between the Star Wars
movies and the Animated Series he said
there's a whole bunch of audience
members that know her and a whole bunch
that don't she has one foot in the Star
Wars that a lot of people know because
of her connection to Anakin and yet
she's all new and can go in her own
Direction in her own way and filoni is
doing just that making Ahsoka essential
summer viewing one other important thing
to note about the show is that it's
being built as a limited series so while
we will undoubtedly see a lot of action
viewers should expect quite a lot of
resolution too hopefully that means the
Ezra and Sabine reunion that Rebels fans
are hoping for will play out in the
live-action series
foreign